expectation. So they so just to let
everybody know now they're talking about
uh you know the uh why Jesus is
qualified to be uh a prophet they were
thinking wrong. So how did he prove that
he's the newest revelation? How did he
prove what he doing the miracles and
doing the other things? How can you know
that Jesus is truly a prophet? Okay.
Good. And speaking from the way he was
speaking now. Good. He did miracles.
He prophesied signs, wonders. Okay. Mhm.
That's how he proved his prophethood. Do
you agree? Yeah. So if you take this
criteria and you apply it to the prophet
Muhammad, then you have to also believe
in the prophet Muhammad. Because for
every one miracle Jesus does, there's 10
of the prophet Muhammad. For one miracle
that Jesus does, there's 10 miracles of
Muhammad. Look, look at this stupid.
Which miracle are we talking about? Are
we talking about the miracle that he
split at the moon? That wasn't even him.
Even if we have to go for that for the
sake of the argument,
which which miracle are we talking
about? Do you want me to destroy this
right away? Go ahead. Okay. Now, number
one, miracles in of themselves. Now,
because the Christian is young, he
doesn't know much, and we're going to
screen share. Miracles in of themselves
do not prove you're a true prophet.
That's first of all. So, share my screen
again. But my problem is with Christians
who are not educated that go there and
give these slobs, these Muhammad and
pagans give them views because number
one, Christians learn your faith. I'm
going to teach you this. The Bible
teaches that miracles in of themselves
are not enough.
So, that's one mistake. miracles in of
themselves. Meaning, if someone does
miracles, that still doesn't prove he's
from God. Okay, I'm going to show you.
Please, may the Holy Spirit give us
perfect recall of scripture. Please
focus. Because the way it's going, it's
probably going to be a three-hour
session with this guy's lies. That's the
first problem. First problem we got
automatically. First problem. All right,
let me show you. Okay, watch here.
God, Lord have mercy on me. Constrain me
from unrighteous anger. here our Lord's
words. Learn your faith. I'm doing it
for you guys. And he's doing his part.
He's going on TikTok because he's
qualified and he'll only address
material he studied. So, he's smart.
He's not going to go into something he
doesn't know because he doesn't want to
shame the Lord because it's not about
his honor or his status. Matthew
24:23-25.
Then if anyone says to you, "Behold,
here's the Christ or there he is, do not
believe him. for false Christ and false
prophets will arise and will show great
signs and wonders. It's in your Bible,
folks.
The Lord said false prophets, false
Christ will do miracles that will be so
convincing that if possible, it would
even deceive the elect if possible. But
he said, "Behold, I've told you in
advance." So even if we say Muhammad did
miracles, that only means his father
Satan filled him and empowered this
demon to do miracles. How do I know?
Because speaking of the man of
lawlessness, the man of sin whom
Muhammad was a picture of. Look what it
says. 2 Thessalonians 2:9-12, whose
coming is in accord with the working of
Satan with all power and signs and false
wonders. and was coming in is accord
with the working of Satan. So the man of
sin, man of lawlessness, he will be
empowered by Satan. Satan will empower
him to do works with all power and signs
and false wonders. See here, our Bible
says Satan has the ability to take
someone and empower them to do things
that in the natural you can't do. And
with all deception of unrighteousness
for those who perish because they did
not receive the love of the truth so as
to be saved. And for this reason God
sends upon them a deliluding influence.
Meaning those who hate the truth, they
hate the truth. They oppose the truth.
They mock the truth. So what God says
there's a level of how much sin he'll
put up with and blasphemy. Then you
blasphe in the spirit. So he goes, he
gives you what you want. So you don't
want the truth. You want to believe the
lie. Here, I'm going to send you a
prophet who will tickle your ears, who
will be a man after your heart, like
Muhammad, who license you to mount
children, to even rape married women,
prostitute them, because that's what you
want. And for this reason, God sends
upon them a deluding influence so that
they will believe what is false. Why? In
order that they all may be judged who
did not believe the truth, but took
pleasure in unrighteousness. This is
their judgment. So, everyone got it?
one more passage, let alone Revelation
13, speaking of Satan, raising up the
beast, the Antichrist, and the second
beast, false prophet, to do miracles in
the power of Satan with the authority of
Satan to deceive people. Here,
Deuteronomy 13:15.
If a prophet or a dreamer of dreams
arises among you and gives you a sign or
a wonder and the sign or the wonder
comes true, now notice God is telling
Israel beforehand. You may have a
prophet or a dreamer who has a dream and
he tells you about a sign and it
happens. Guys, are you reading? Read
with me and pay attention.
And it happens,
right? and the wonder comes true or the
miracle he does happens concerning which
he spoke to you saying let us walk after
other gods whom you have not known and
let us serve them. You shall not listen
to the words of that prophet or that
dreamer of dreams. Don't listen to him.
Why? For Yahweh your God is testing you
to find out if you love Yahweh your God
with all your heart and with all your
soul. You shall walk after Yahweh your
God and fear him and you shall keep his
commandments. listen to his voice,
served him and cling to him. But that
prophet or that dream of dreams shall be
put to death. Now if Muhammad was living
at the time of the kings and the judges,
they would have killed him, stoned him,
and buried him. But when Muhammad
prophesied, Israel did not have the
power, right? But that prophet or that
dream of dreams shall be put to death
because he has counseledled rebelling
against Yahweh your God who brought you
from the land of Egypt and redeemed you
from the house of slavery to drive you
from the way in which Yahweh your God
commanded you to walk. So you shall
purge the evil from among you. So number
one, God already warned you there'll be
people are going to do miracles, but
they're being empowered by Satan there.
Muhammad was. So, how are you going to
know if he's of Satan or of God? If he
preaches the same God and brings the
same consistent message. Now, it's why
watch my series.
I don't want to keep talking, but this
is important when it comes to the Bible.
Watch my series because someone will
say, because I know what lesbian will
say, well, hey, don't the Catholics say
Muslims and Christians worship the same
God? Go watch my series to explain what
the statements mean. I've read the
statements. I've showed you what the
statements mean in context and what
they're referring to. So, let me be real
quick.
The statements both from Eastern
Orthodox and it's not it's not just
Catholics. See, this is what the Eastern
Orthodox I want to tell you. Eastern
Orthodox official statements and the
patriarchs of the Eastern Orthodox
Church in agreement with the with the
Catholic Church say. Yes, Jews, Muslims,
and Christians adore the same God. But
when you read the statements in context
like I did in my series, what the
catechism and Vatican 2 is saying is to
those Muslims and Jews who are ignorant
and to no fault of their own, I read it,
do not know the true gospel, the true
Jesus and the God revealed in Jesus.
They don't know.
These individuals are not guilty and
culpable because their scripture, their
tradition tells them it's the God of
Abraham. So, we take them where they're
at. We meet them where they're at. So,
you believe in the God of Abraham. Well,
let me tell you who this God of Abraham
is according to the revelation of Jesus
Christ. After
you give them the revelation that the
God of Abraham you worship says this
about Jesus and Jesus says this about
him and you give them a clear
presentation from that moment on they
have no excuse and if they reject then
they are worshiping a false god a false
Christ. Yep. Exactly. To prepare them
for the gospel. Now if they reject the
gospel then and that means serve the
father the devil. Right. according to
these statements. Yeah. And I will
explain it more in the later part
tonight. God will only with your
prayers. I'm healthy and holy. Go watch
my series, guys. You got to watch it. I
went in depth and I showed you this is
what it means. When someone tells you,
"Oh, mama did miracles." So what? That
only means that Satan, his father,
helped him do miracles. You want to add
anything before I refute the rest of it?
No, no, no. You could go ahead, brother.
Okay. Second problem. Second problem is
this.
our Lord. The Bible says that
you must
come in confirmation of the revelation
already established. What do I mean? The
Bible says a prophet will be known by
his faithfulness
to the revelation already established
and believed on. meaning Isaiah has to
come and confirm the prophets that came
before him and Moses. Why do you think
all throughout the New Testament our
Lord Jesus and his followers are
constantly pointing to the Old
Testament, pointing to the prophecies
and confirming that they accept the Old
Testament and they confirm the Old
Testament. They don't contradict the New
the Old Testament, but they're building
on it. So, let me show you what I mean.
So it's not just miracles.
It's miracles done
in confirmation
of the previous revelation. Watch here
the principle.
Watch the principle. And I'm going to
show you that Muhammad agreed with this
principle. He confirmed it. Okay. Luke
24:25 27. Let me give you more one more
here.
Right here. 1 Corinthians 15:104.
Now I may make known to you, brothers,
the gospel which I proclaimed as good
news to you, which also you received,
and which also you stand, by which also
you are saved, if you hold fast to the
word which I proclaimed to you as good
news, unless you believe for nothing.
For I deliver to you, now notice as of
first importance what I also received,
that Christ died for our sins according
to the scriptures. You see, the Jews
knew their Old Testament. Jesus became a
Jewish man to confirm the Old Testament
that he revealed. So it was Jesus in the
Old Testament who says any prophet who
contradicts the revelation already
established is a false prophet. So two
things a prophet must do. Not only
provide supernatural verification he's
of God, but he must confirm and agree
with the previous scriptures and not
contradict them. Muhammad fails both
counts. For I delivered to you as first
importance what I also received that
Christ died for our sins according to
the scriptures. And he was buried and he
was raised on a third day according to
the scriptures. All right. Look what
Jesus says. Luke 24:25-27.
And he said to them and he said to them,
oh foolish ones and slow of heart to
believe in all that the prophets have
spoken. Was it not necessary for the
Christ to suffer these things and enter
into enter his glory? Then beginning
with Moses and with all the prophets, he
interpreted to them the things
concerning himself and all the
scriptures. Did everyone see it? Are you
guys seeing the principle? If Jesus had
done miracles,
but did not confirm the Old Testament
and fulfill prophecies about him, then
all this would prove to the Jews he's a
sorcerer. That you know what the Jews
said about Jesus' miracles? Now, I want
you to listen. They didn't deny Jesus
did miracles. They admit he did
miracles. They said, "But he was a
sorcerer and he misled Israel by
sorcery."
So if you are listening, the Jews admit
Jesus did miracles. But to the Jews,
Jesus is a false prophet. Why? Because
they thought he contradicted the Torah.
So the Jews say Jesus did miracles. They
admit that. It's even in the tomood. But
they go, he did it by sorcery, by magic.
And some traditions say the sorcery he
learned in Egypt. Why? Because they know
their Old Testament.
And they know in their Old Testament,
miracles are not enough because they're
warned. People do miracles, but that the
messenger must confirm the Old
Testament. So you understand why our
Lord is saying, I'm not just doing
miracles, but the miracles are
supernatural confirmation that I'm the
one that the prophet said would come. So
I'm also fulfilling prophecy,
which Muhammad did not do. Finally, Luke
24:44 to 47.
Now he said to them, "These are my words
which I spoke to you while I was still
with you that all things which are
written about me in the law of Moses."
Notice written about me in the law of
Moses and the prophet Psalms. This is
why Orthodox Muslim because you told me
he's going to go into the Old Testament
because he has to show where the
prophets announced the son of Satan
Muhammad.
Moses and the prophet psalms must be
fulfilled. Then he opened their minds
and understand the scriptures and he
said to them, "Thus it is written that
the Christ would suffer and rise again
from the dead the third day and that
repentance for forgiveness of sins would
be proclaimed in his name to all the
nations beginning from Jerusalem." So
even if Muhammad did miracles, that
doesn't mean he's from God. It means
that Satan is empowering.